(upbeat music)
- We're pushing into a
12-plus-hour day and then some.
- [Narrator] Dennis
Tajer is one of more than
a hundred thousand pilots in the US
grappling with this
summer's travel demand.
It's led to chaotic scenes from long lines
at LaGuardia Airport to seas
of baggage in Frankfurt.
- What I'm seeing right
now, I have never seen
in my 30 plus years at the airlines.
- [Narrator] Tajer is also a spokesman
for the Allied Pilots Association,
a union representing
American Airlines pilots.
The two sides are currently
in the middle of negotiations
over a new contract.
And Tajer says they're
understaffed and overwhelmed.
- So there is this global
airline pilot shortage,
and it's not something that can be quickly
or easily addressed.
- [Narrator] While
travelers have returned,
there are 230,000 fewer workers
across the industry than there
were before the pandemic.
We look at how all this is taking a toll
and how the industry is trying
to fix things for pilots.
(plane roaring)
The root of the problem goes back to 2020.
Lockdowns and travel restrictions due
to the pandemic stifled most
air travel around the world.
To survive, the aviation industry
scaled back its workforce
with the four largest US carriers alone
losing more than 4,000 pilots in 2020.
This shortage is being felt most acutely
by regional carriers,
who've pulled out of some
routes with fewer passengers
restricting access to smaller cities.
- Pilots are being stretched
at some airlines to their limits.
- [Narrator] Henry
Harteveldt is the founder
of Atmosphere Research,
an airline and travel
industry analysis group.
He says that this shortage has upended
the control pilots have
over their schedules.
Each month, airlines share
a roster of upcoming flights
with pilots choosing the ones they want.
Any remaining flights are
left up for grabs for pilots
that have some extra time.
- They earn more money as a result
when they fly those trips.
So it's a win-win for the
pilot and the airline.
- [Narrator] But the predictability
of this system broke down in the summer
when the travel season was hit
by extreme weather, technical
glitches and other snafus.
Flight schedules had very
little buffer room to deal
with these unexpected issues.
- [Dennis] Some of 'em
are 10, 11 hour days.
That's basically gonna give me about
little over an hour of buffer.
- [Narrator] And the
resulting fight delays
and cancellations left both
passengers and staff uncertain
about when they would be flying.
This unpredictability has made some pilots
hesitant to take extra flights.
- There is a deep resistance
to actually go pick up time.
Once you're in the system,
they come in and say,
"Guess what? You're not going home.
You're gonna go for another day or two."
- [Narrator] To manage a
challenge facing pilots
as well as other staffing
shortages across the industry,
some airlines are
adjusting their scheduling.
American Airlines said during
its July earnings call,
that it would reduce scheduled flights
for at least the rest of the year.
- [Robert] We pulled out
some additional flying
and that's flying that we would rather do.
- [Narrator] This is a
painful decision to make
after the industry spent
about two years waiting
for demand to return.
- Obviously this comes at a cost.
For one thing, they
still have all the pilots
that they have on payroll.
They've got the lease or debt payment
to make on all of those aircraft.
And they have all of the
other employees on staff
who have to be paid.
- [Narrator] The cutting flights
won't fix another problem.
Quickly replacing the pilots
lost during the pandemic.
- It's incredibly difficult
to get these wings.
- [Narrator] Pilots have to go
through a wide range of tests
and licensing requirements,
as well as fly for 1500 hours
before they can start working
for a commercial airline.
- [Dennis] A hundred
thousand dollars just to
get the certification,
let alone the amount
of time and money you'll
have to spend to get
the experience to move forward.
- [Narrator] Aviation
analysts and flight schools
in the US say, it can take
up to two to four years
to get the required
training and experience.
- These young pilots coming through,
some of them they have to
provide for their families
while they're flying these in-between jobs
to get that experience.
- [Narrator] To make this
process easier American Airlines
said it's focusing on removing training
and financial barriers for its aviators
through its Cadet Academy and
faster training will be key,
because 2022 is already
the busiest year on record
for pilot hiring.
Major US carriers are
also on track to hire
more than 10,000 of them this year
according to one pilot advisory firm.
As of August, American Airlines alone
had hired over 1,200 pilots.
- The airlines are not doing nothing.
They're doing all they can.
The challenge is that they
need to be doing more.
- [Narrator] As the summer
travel surge begins to fade,
airlines are hoping to
avoid the same snafus
during the winter holiday season.
American Airlines said the
reduced flight schedule
in the fall will give
them space to prepare
for the end of this year.
- [Vasu] And then as we go
forward into later September,
October, and deeper into the winter,
we have time yet to go and
figure out how that goes.
- [Narrator] But it
may be too late by then
as the summer experience
has put off some customers.
One survey found that 17%
of leisure travelers said
they're less likely to fly
over Christmas and New Year
because of airline
disruptions during the summer.
- This is what we are
alarmed by right now,
less costing and a cost
isn't just in money.
The cost is in the trust.
(gentle music)